president biden trying to make the case
that the economy is in good shape after
a supply crisis and inflation took a
huge bite out of his approval numbers
biden rolling out a new plan to fight
off rising prices at the gas pump by
releasing 50 million barrels of oil from
our strategic petroleum reserves
today i'm announcing
that the largest ever release from the
u.s strategic petroleum reserve to help
provide the supply we need as we recover
from this pandemic i also want to
briefly address one myth about inflated
gas prices they're not due to
environmental measures
my effort to combat climate change is
not raising the price of gas
or increasing its availability
and energy secretary jennifer granholm
being criticized for the answer to this
question
there's various figures about this i'm
curious if you know how many barrels of
oil does the us consume per day i don't
have that number in front of me so
dana yeah what say you okay so you
should probably know that if you're the
secretary of energy
i'm just gonna suggest
fossil fuels so tapping the sp so joe
biden talks about how long he's been in
washington and how much experience he
has and
any president that tries to tap the
strategic petroleum reserve in order to
deal with prices we're not actually in
an oil emergency
it's like a nap on a
elephant it doesn't have the impact that
it wants it to and also it's just so
craven right they do it right before
thanksgiving and tapping the spr is
really just making up for the bad policy
from before so canceling keystone
cancelling oil and gas leases
discouraging investment not allowing
anwar to go through so then you have to
tap the spr which is not going to do
anything and you get through
thanksgiving and they're just like
basically hoping that it all goes away
it was the same thing with the eviction
moratorium that wasn't working out the
money wasn't going out the door so then
they had to like figure out other policy
and then they had to go to the courts
and they basically get saved by the
courts and told they can't do that or
they're driving up inflation with bad
policy and now they're like oh wait now
what are we going to do because of
inflation so it's like one thing after
another but the other thing about
jennifer granhall and the secretary is
yesterday she and she's not the only one
the administration's position on this
has been
higher gas prices are the price that all
of us are going to have to pay as so
that we can transition to a cleaner
fuel for the climate that's what they've
said
so she said that yesterday today she's
in the briefing room saying this is a
very serious issue it affects all
low-income families we're going to get
on top of it so somebody called her
between yesterday and today when they
realized that their polling is so bad on
this just now there was a poll that said
that 77 of people say they notice
inflation and 57 of them blame joe biden
whether that's fair or not that's the
reality that they're living in well to
that point jesse there's another poll
out that for 54 of americans the raising
gas and grocery prices are a major
concern so that's the highest level
of concern for them joe doesn't seem
very concerned does he he
i guess wants higher prices he said it
it makes it easier to transition to
green he just doesn't want to pay a
political price for the high gas prices
so they do this silly release which does
nothing it's like what do we consume
digging 20 million barrels a day and and
he releases 50 million that's like your
mother oil went up today it did okay
there you go that is like your mother
asking you to bring over something for
thanksgiving and you show up with two
triscuits
[Laughter]
what is that going to do i don't know
we're not going to get anywhere he's
been begging opec opec's just going to
give him the middle finger the crown
prince hates him because joe called him
a pariah after he murdered that
journalist so it's like a blood feud and
the american people are going to pay a
press
hey you know what he's taking it out on
the american people
calling kyle written house of white
supremacists
okay
so one thing that i find difficult to
square brian is so 70 of americans have
a negative outlook on the economy right
now but we do have the stock market
surge low unemployment wages going up
especially in the lower paid sectors
why do you think that that's happening i
i think it's because practical use uh
when you walk in you know joe biden says
everything's back on the shelves which
is miraculous because it's not but if he
said it i guess it works he says
everything's back on the shelves the
supply chain problem basically solved so
if you look at the things that you go to
buy are more expensive things you go to
buy a lot of times we don't have them
you're going to put gas in your car it
costs more you actually try to buy stuff
and you pay more and get less you go out
to a restaurant and it costs more the
service isn't as good people are not
working sundays that restaurants you
like is closed because they're not
staffed so in all these little areas
around the country you're affected and
it affects or the practical way we lead
our lives which i find fascinating
because it's apolitical everything i
just mentioned has nothing to do with
the republican philosophy or democratic
philosophy it's making people say is my
life better now than it was and who is
responsible for it and he's always for
somebody so experienced with experienced
staff i don't understand why he's always
in reaction mode he's never leading like
we got to get ahead of inflation we got
to get ahead of the concern about gas
and oil and now he reacts just a day
before he goes to a billionaire's house
uh in nantucket yeah so it's interesting
about the day-to-day the
well the ceo of walmart was on tv
talking about thanking president biden
for fixing the supply chain crisis and
the ceo of etsy so over five million
small businesses that are
yeah he said this was a better year than
last year
what do you make of that well walmart's
big enough that one it fixed its own
problem because they were able to lease
their own ships to make sure their
stores were stopped they're saying out
loud don't worry about the stores the
shows being empty because they don't
want to discourage people from coming to
shop they're never going to tell you oh
things are not in stock and they're also
scared
their pants are in a twist over these
cuckoo communists who are working in
this administration so
that's the political calculation on ba
on behalf of walmart but in terms of joe
biden the only thing i can think about
is he's intentionally put
deeply stupid people in these jobs so
they can say stupid things which
actually help cover up what the real
intention is because jen's
if they screw up and tell you the truth
it
thank them for that if they they make a
mistake like jen granholm but i was
reading kyle bass on twitter he was just
working down the numbers that with the
world because it's a global commodity it
could it consumes 100 million barrels
per day so we release 50 million barrels
from the strategic petroleum reserve
kyle bass it's a rounding error expect a
hundred dollar oil five dollars a gallon
for gasoline for years to come because
of the damage that uh wow
this year
uh 18 a day okay yeah it's
20 million and
refined product i think